good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-804 object class
Keter special containment procedures
until such time as scp-804 is found to
be without any mimetic effect it is to
remain in its original location at the
former site of Alaska where exposure to
the elements prevents its reactivation a
30 by 30 camouflage tarp is to be
maintained over scp-804 and facilities
for armed guards and testing are to be
maintained 130 metres from its location
trespassers are to be treated with a
class a amnesiac and returned to the
nearest town of or terminated at the
discretion of on-site security in the
event of scp-804 being approached or
seized by hostile armed force
contingency 804 X is to be executed
description scp-804 is the remains of an
art installation titled world without
man revealed on 2000 by the defunct
artists group who nail Matt Parra masta
male Master apologies or the
pronunciation I have no idea how I'm
supposed to say that but I'm sure you'll
let me know
moving on according to the documentation
retrieved and deleted from the artists
website during cleanup procedure scp-804
was originally a large clear globe of
the earth with several smaller Globes
and video equipment within promotional
material on the website implied that the
globe was to display images of pastoral
wilderness untouched by mankind
contrasted with visuals of abandoned
human industry and decaying landmarks
upon activation before a small audience
of prominent environmental activists and
artists from the nearby community of his
CP 804 began to display its destructive
property
we can only speculate if the device's
output was intentional or not as those
involved in its construction perished
during the incident or have gone into
hiding
while the globe's within scp-804 rotate
all man-made artifacts with an
approximately 100 meters begin to
rapidly deteriorate until completely
disintegrated the effect applies to
anything ranging from machinery to
buildings clothing plastics synthetic
chemical compounds and any tool more
complex than a sharpened stick of wood
the area of affect grows the longer the
device is active with the effect growing
even stronger at its source
human tissue is also affected at a
slower rate of decay causing victims to
become emaciated as they lose body mass
leading up to the collapse of their
skeleton and death
with the bodies swiftly breaking down
into component matters shortly
thereafter non-human life is completely
unaffected persons who escaped the area
of effect experienced symptoms similar
to prolonged starvation but can return
to full health with proper care if not
for the fact that it is not entirely
immune to its own effect scp-804 would
have the potential to remove all trace
of humanity from the globe in a matter
of weeks
judging from the observed rate of
destruction upon original activation
versus its current capabilities under
testing scp-804 scape abilities have
been impaired by the damage it caused to
itself however sustained use still
presents an extreme threat especially if
the device is somehow refined or
repaired due to the circumstances in
which scp-804 was secured it is strongly
believed that the device also possesses
some form of mental compulsion on those
who view it but testing is still ongoing
to determine if that property has also
been compromised by the decay of scp-804
and how it might be contained see
recovery log for further information
recovery log scp-804 approximately five
minutes after activation the effect of
scp-804 reached the nearby community of
citizens who are not at the art show
initially responded with panic and made
several emergency calls due to the
extreme remote location of the town the
first response was made by a small
single prop aircraft which arrived about
30 minutes later although the plane
entered the area of effect and was
quickly lost the pilot did relay a radio
message describing the swift and
complete destruction of the town's
buildings at this point the foundation
became aware of the situation and teams
of agents were sent to investigate by
the time agents were able to arrive on
scene scp-804 had been intermittently
active for nearly eight hours and as a
result the town and everything in a
radius of people was wiped clean of any
trace of human civilization upon arrival
one plane was immediately affected
fortunately the crew was able to make an
emergency landing before the physical
structure of the plane collapsed around
them unfortunately their equipment and
clothing was also quickly disintegrated
exposing them to the extreme cold of
northern Alaska as a result six agents
had to be treated for hypothermia but
all are expected to return to duty with
no lasting effects after recovering the
crew of the downed plane agents set up a
perimeter and were able to observe the
epicenter of scp-804 s effect the
surviving population of had crowded
around the remains of the device all
subjects observed were severely
emaciated and suffering from severe
hypothermia the exposure had only
worsened the effect of scp-804 and many
subjects were observed with missing
digits and even limbs the survivors were
approaching the device in teams of two
to three to push it the single remaining
globe within scp-804 housing in order to
maintain its effect as each subject
eventually succumbed and collapsed
another from the crowd of onlookers
would shuffle former to take their place
survivors were seen to be cheering and
encouraging those
were maintaining the device until their
turn to push the frosting vote came up
although such manual operation was not
sufficient to maintain even the radius
of effect the device had achieved before
damaging itself agents were authorized
by all 5.2 opened fire on the crowd
although bullets experienced the same
decay as any other artifact their
velocity was enough to strike lethal
wounds before decomposition when the
remaining globe of scp-804 ceased to
spin the effect ended and agents were
able to move in and secure the device
survivors attempted to resist but lack
the strength to impede Foundation agents
and began to act in a disorientated
manner once they were removed from a CP
804 with no adequate facilities
remaining to provide shelter for them
all many survivors chose to simply lie
down in the snow and die while others
attempted to provoke agents into using
lethal force upon them those who were
taken into custody refused to answer any
questions and were able to refuse enough
care that they did not recover from
their physical decay as exposure to the
extreme elements of northern Alaska
appears to adequately contain a CP 804
by freezing its remaining machinery in
place it was decided to leave the device
on-site and under guard along with it in
the unlikely event that a hostile
faction attempts to secure the device
addendum scp-804 is not to be contained
within any foundation facility until it
is certain that we will be able to
prevent anyone from being compelled to
activate or maintain the rotation of the
globe even a few minutes of scp-804 s
effect could destroy its own containment
and seriously compromised any other
containment nearby
contingency 804 X mimetic research
report revised July 2011 by dr. Johannes
sorts this is the third annual review of
any supernatural mimetic component to
scp-804 and we still have not produced
any significant results it's time to put
the controversy on scp-804 memetic
properties to rest once and for all
yes scp-804 possesses memetic properties
and yes these properties were
responsible for driving the survivors of
its activation event into sacrificing
themselves to maintain the device but
there is nothing especially virulent or
dangerous about scp-804 s memetic
properties only a few select personality
types outlined in the attached report
have any desire to reactivate the device
most notable are the d-class sociopaths
who show similar amusement when
presented with a big red button that
says kill everything we've been looking
at this all wrong
there's no magical compulsion that could
drive so many people to destroy
themselves there doesn't need to be
everything we observed during recovery
can be explained by mundane group
dynamics and human nature the device had
just wiped away all trace of the work
and the lives of a reclusive artist and
activist community the building's
crumbled into dust so fast that the
people were not even injured in its
collapse and at the center of it all a
world without man turned around and
around on its increasingly rickety
platform offering a deadly premise that
had been presented to them as an ideal
a cure for the virus known as humanity
so why did a group of activists throw
themselves and their neighbors into the
deadly workings of a machine that they
thought was going to wipe all human life
off Mother Earth they simply wanted to
do it
okay that about does it for today thank
you all for listening and you are all
dismissed
goodbye you know I'm gonna need a hobby
so many of these things are a goddamn
bummer I'm going for lunch
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre bashert
Muslim wookie Jax Marik Pierce M Hamlin
Austin Thomas Aldridge
Desmond Hoskins Depp's McGee
dr. mortis Johnno Porter
Judi Dench Tiber ball and sy7 actual if
you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you